cause they got this one story where it
says Neo condemns parents allowing
children to transition and he's he
responded first and foremost I condemn
no one who might have condemned anybody
your life your kids your choice I was
asked the question I answered it my
opinion is mine I'm not asking anybody
to agree with me nor am I telling you
what you can and cannot do with your
children I say to my opinion on the
matter and that's that why should i k
why should I care if my opinion upsets
you when you don't care if yours upsets
anyone opinions aren't special
we all have one people voice them
regularly whether they've asked or not
dude that was based why should I care if
my opinion upsets you when you don't
care if your opinion upsets anyone else
yeah that's exactly but that's just
that's been true for you yeah he is
hilarious so there you go I'm proud of
him I'll just say it I'm proud of him
yeah I want to buy some Neil Murray
chapters
out we got to get uh Neo Jersey or
whatever to hang on the wall like yeah
yeah Luke did with Kyrie Irving okay no
but I think there's something to be said
about that I mean why should he have to
guard his opinion based on what random
people on the internet think of him